[Music]
oh hello there happy Mandy Moore sure is
pleased to meet you look at it they're
up and for classic black for our wedding
reception she looks so great now before
that she was the perfect blushing bride
for her I Do's to musician Taylor
goldsmith meanwhile the good news
continues for Mandy's TV daughter and
son-in-law on this is us Chris Sullivan
telling me Kate and Toby's happiness
will not be short-lived we finally got
the news that you guys are pregnant
should I be afraid to be really happy
you know what if they were to to throw
us a curveball in this situation I would
quit I was gonna say I quit instant
cancellation TV thought tonight's
Thanksgiving episode is being called
unforgettable with clues about Jack's
relationship with this mystery woman a
brought food and a look at Toby looking
happier at family dinner Chris promises
his character will make it through this
low point but you know I had to ask the
big question why didn't you have your
ring off what's that when we saw the
flash floor I just you know as much as
we love you on this is us it's so cool
to see you in camp oh yeah that was a
good time so what was working with
Jennifer Garner like she's incredible to
work with she works harder than anyone
else and shows up with baked goods
it's insane she worked like 14 hours a
day and then go home and and bake with
her kids for three or four hours and
bring enough for everybody any chance
that you could recruit her for an
episode of this is oh that's good I'm
sure she thought she would do it come on
Jennifer you do it have you like this is
us who could she play how could she
maybe she could play her I mean secret
Sullivan turns out her is Jennifer
Jennifer Garner as herself
[Music]